when that you know when the Jets get
slaughtered on Monday Night Football I
tend to get the [ __ ] out of town
[Music]
it's a
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this was the last Monday morning in her
life
[Applause]
what the morning
granny hobby sir
airport life
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm Gary Vaynerchuk I started my career
as an entrepreneur I was born in the
former Soviet Union and immigrated to
the US when I was a kid anybody have
questions anything like very specific or
yes I have no idea so I'm paying
attention to things but the truth is I
don't think we need to be crippled by
what's next that's let's go back to TV
terms that's like me being an NBC
executive right now and you ask me
what's the next hit show so you can run
a commercial on it the way I think about
those logos is they are the most
important things right now and when
Seinfeld and Friends and Empire or the
number one shows you run ads against it
and when they're not you don't I love
when people ask me like well Gary what
if what if instagrams not here in four
years I'm like well then we'll spend our
money somewhere else you know I think we
have these different emotional feelings
towards these new platforms that we did
not have towards television when
Seinfeld cancelled you went somewhere
else but I have no emotion to where the
end consumers attention is I've been
studying Drivetime radio Drivetime radio
prices continue to come down they're
going to get low enough to them where
I'm gonna be like you know what I'm
gonna buy that and what I try to do is
suffocate any debate by making it a a B
test or a bake-off between whatever you
believe and whatever I believe and then
let's deploy it on how much you're
selling at Albertson's in the state of
Missouri you run yours
I'll run mine let's see and the three or
four companies that I've been able to
actually put in that corner because I'm
tired of debating marketing mixes that
were built to justify TV spend like
where is the common sense against the
math here like go take one outside math
person and have them audit the way
you're scoring internally and they laugh
it's built to justify traditional
behavior
let's make this about the ethos of 2017
which is the fact that we are looking to
become the number one storytellers in
that format and this is the account
that's giving us the most assets has the
most upside we want to really show them
and like let's make it an offensive move
instead of a defensive move
[Music]
good talk uh my clients a digital
off-site so some fun characters from
snapchat YouTube all the players bustle
um technical difficulties on the flight
from Chicago gave us a little bit of a
loop little curveball but into our day
now here in Chicago now having another
meeting with a potential client and just
uh just hold a lot of vaynermedia work
tonight which is good you know that's
what I do for a living this Gary Vee is
my side hustle super pumped to be here
actually just thinking back to our
awesome Budweiser video that was done in
this great town those Kobe fans like my
best friend Brandon actually put a
little uh can we click within got it
anyway just put play the little
Budweiser video and we'll put a link in
the YouTube you haven't seen the bud
work by vaynermedia amazing job by the
clients made in the context in the air
cover just really fun right where's my
lunch
[Music]
[Music]
we have no interest in being paid for
something that we aren't bringing value
on and we have no interest in nickel and
diming any client you know within any
shape or form so our intent on
whatever's needed how long finish what
is going to be more predicated on what's
right for you guys
than what's right for us period in the
story that's what client services is in
the right way and so I think you know
that which excites me and so that's the
truth I just want to reiterate that well
we'll assess and whatever is the right
thing to do as if we owned all three
companies yours there's a mine that's
what we will do yep it's important all
which iris can respond yeah it episode
102 I just finished it good it's real
good stuff I think you guys are like it
take a look cute today
[Music]
pretty pretty subjective and anecdotal
to like my mood right this second but I
would say that waiting for a car nuber
d-roc is here Tyler's here kind of
figured out something new with Tyler he
travels with me more now and it's been
more efficient it's kind of interesting
insight for anybody that's really crazy
I know most of you that are watching or
not rolling with assistant let alone
willing to pay for that assistant to
travel but for any of you that are it's
an interesting thing I did not think it
was going to be a good idea it's turned
out to be a very good idea
and just looking for you know always
looking a hack and we just been more
efficient getting [ __ ] done so
I like that
are we done little little sidenote
Chicago looking right
had a bunch of meetings today with
clients and prospective clients and
wanted to put some meat on this episode
I just don't understand sales people
it's it's you know it's actually a
really interesting trait that allows
somebody to be a good sales person it
comes down to empathy are you able to
put yourself in the other person's shoes
I know what I want I know how I want it
to be but the reason bader media has
been successful is because I haven't
been stubborn about forcing all of my
clients who are nine billion dollar
companies to do it my way I'm a little
stumble
I'm a speedboat you know me as a brand
person is a human cube teeny-tiny
vaynermedia small 100 million small and
so and so you need to be empathetic I
know how you want it to be I know when
you're hitting me up for 15 minutes of
your my time what you want out of it
what do I want out of it what do I get
out of it and that's what I do 24/7 365
I check my wants at the door when I go
in sales mode and that's the flip
reverse of how most of you roll
you know it's always interesting to see
when you get in patters like right now
I'm just deeply deeply entrenched and
engaging heavily into my Instagram
community literally it's been building
and then I come up with a 60-second Club
and literally then it's like the
universe gives back today the Harding
and liking of comments which allows me
to even scale my engagement even more
here's some love for King poppin here's
some love for bouche man staff here's
some pot love for lucky at lore seven
you know what I mean classic Gabe get
some love do you rock classic Gabe get
some love see the ruies love Omar CA
love fabulous Fredrik love n JW official
love Cody Sudha loved Sage spiesse loved
just love Daniel Ayala underscores and
dots everywhere love crash Brooks can't
comprehend the grind you can do it too
we can all do it do you know why you're
doing it
yes good job d-roc I already forgot
after one day
Kimberly Vincent being smart saying that
I would love to win five minutes with
Gary not a physical gift not even a car
and I'm replying that's
that's coming soon
so hello now yo
hi hey it's Gary
no I'm in Chicago headed to the airport
head to LA living the dream when that
you know when the Jets get slaughtered
on Monday Night Football I tend to get
the [ __ ] out of town I think it's a huge
huge flaw of most leaders like do you
think I'm most proud of is I can be sold
on anything
at the same time nobody believes in
their [ __ ] more than me
you know like [ __ ] I'm open for business
like when did you see my face when you
came to me and said maybe I should
travel with you I'm like nah but you
know it's turned out to be right
so open for business yeah I just just
don't want to have lines in the sand
yeah other than [ __ ] you Patriots
[Applause]
this yours cog Oh
I always do it to you in and out it's
the funniest I just don't know why I
don't have the ability to to actually
stay in Chicago for the night and just
every time same thing I wish I could
sing cuz right now it's saying girl you
know it's true by uh by Milli Vanilli
but I just don't have it
girl you know this girl you know it's
true
[Music]
[Music]
alright alright alright alright alright
see like a Matthew McConaughey from
Dazed and Confused all right we are
picking somebody right now on Instagram
for the 60-second Club first one Ferno
we've done some sign books first one I'm
filming on daily being what we gave away
on this one is $200 deployed against
your pick of sneakers
we like sneakers we're wearing the same
sneakers today which is a devastating
heard Gary they're awesome
and anybody who wants to keep selling
sneakers I'm super into it I'll continue
to give shoutouts because that will
excite people to send me more sneakers
ten and a half's lane making it love and
it's working $50 or $90 or $400 for the
exposure right don't send stickers I'm
good here we go the first person to win
pair of sneakers
is going to be somebody very nice sweet
very cool who's in the 62nd club just
picking a couple people
yeah picking a random I'm just like kind
of I'm looking at what people like you
know people that just put hashtag
60-second Club like I'm looking for
originality I'm looking for anybody
that's got is giving me love in their
profile picture that's a that's a quick
way to scam me into winning something
good so we're gonna go with are you
getting in here we're gonna go with
Fitness Jones training Congrats my man
you've won correct my man
and that's why I win the combination of
running the marathon I don't need it
right now I'm patient as [ __ ] and I
really give a [ __ ] about what you want
it's why you like me
it's why this content works it's why all
these things work because I think about
you I don't think about myself and so we
need to deploy empathy you think you're
good salesman show me by deploying
massive empathy and awareness to the
other person they're not stupid they
don't not get it they don't get it the
way you want it cuz usually it's for you
matter of you trying to sell me right
now in the comments on insta I know what
you want but I just want to sell it to
somebody you need to understand what
they want
that just came out of straight living
knowing what I just did the last 12
hours and then going in these comment
sections and people just just not
deploying empathy if you want something
you need to reverse engineer the other
person thank you so much thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]